earlier in this course we talked about
the changing role of labor unions and
how the decline in union membership has
contributed to the breakdown of the
social contract to understand this
better let's look at how union
membership rates have changed since
their peak in the 1950s when almost
one-third of all employees belong to a
union by the early 1980s around the time
when we begin to see the real effects of
the breakdown of the social contract
Union membership was already declining
and from then until now it declined even
more dramatically in 2013 only 11% of
129 million working individuals in the
US had a union on a job and collective
bargaining at work now in the private
sector which employs most working
individuals in the u.s. this percentage
is even lower barely 7 percent of these
workers in fast food health care or
technology for example nearly 7% have a
union at work now labor leaders and
scholars who study employment and labor
unions argue that a number of factors
have contributed to this decline in
unions some argue for example that the
structure of the economy plays a role as
growth in non-union sectors concentrated
in service industries has outstripped
growth in industries like construction
and manufacturing where unions
historically have been strong others
point to the increased difficulty of
organizing new membership and in
particular to the legal obstacles that
exist in implementing new agreements at
work recent research has found that only
1 in 7 workplaces where workers have
organized an election and voted for a
union will actually see a contract in
the year following their vote and
oftentimes these types of elections are
contentious and in workplaces where
employers have been charged with trying
to discourage union activity through
unfair labor practices the odds go down
by nearly a third
in addition to these economic and legal
challenges labor leaders and scholars
also point to increased anti-union
activity not only by employers but
increasingly by policy makers as we've
seen in states like Wisconsin
in Indiana or rolling back workers
rights to organize and collective
bargaining agreements so over the past
three decades there's really been a
shift not only and how many people
experience labor unions on the job but
in the way that we think about labor
unions in this course we've talked about
the social contract and what it means at
work this idea that what's good for
workers is good for businesses and
although we have examples of many good
employers as discussed by Professor
Zeynep Don in her video many employers
act as though this idea is no longer the
case that what's good for workers is not
necessarily good for businesses and that
unions do not have a role in improving
the way that firms work at the same time
declining wages less job security and
increased costs related to things like
health care and student loans are making
it more difficult for working
individuals all of this adds up to a
difficult environment not only for labor
unions but also for individuals who try
to protect their rights on the job the
good news however is that over the past
two decades we've had a flurry of
activity and organizing around economic
justice in ways that are bringing
employees voices front and center these
include new strategies of labor unions
to expand their membership and include
more working people the growth of worker
centers and labor associations outside
this realm and the strengthening of
employment policy through economic
development we've also seen a growing
number of social movements that are
highlighting the ways in which the
social contract can be reestablished at
work in the next video we'll talk about
each of these in a bit more detail
you